Microsoft announced the new multi-year
multi-billion dollar reported to be 10
billion dollars investment into open AI
can you describe the thinking uh that
went into this and what what are the
pros what are the cons of working with a
company like Microsoft
it's not all
perfect or easy but on the whole they
have been an amazing partner to us
Satya and Kevin McHale
are are super aligned with us super
flexible have gone like way above and
beyond the Call of Duty to do things
that we have needed to get all this to
work
this is like a big Iron complicated
engineering project
and they are a big and complex company
and
I think like many great Partnerships or
relationships we've sort of just
continued to ramp up our investment in
each other
and it's been very good
it's a for-profit company it's very
driven
it's very large scale
is there pressure to kind of make a lot
of money I think most other companies
wouldn't maybe now they would it
wouldn't at the time have understood why
we needed all the weird control
Provisions we have and why we need all
the kind of like AGI specialness
um
and I know that because I talked to some
other companies before we did the first
deal with Microsoft
um and I think they were they are unique
in terms of the companies at that scale
that understood why we needed the
control Provisions we have
and so those control Provisions help you
help make sure that uh the capitalist
imperative does not
affect the development of AI
well let me just ask you as an aside
about Sacha and Adela the CEO of
Microsoft he seems to have successfully
transformed Microsoft into into this
fresh Innovative developer friendly
company I agree what do you I mean is it
really hard to do for a very large
company
uh what what have you learned from him
why do you think he was able to do this
kind of thing
um
yeah what what insights do you have
about why this one human being is able
to contribute to the pivot of a large
company into something very new
I think most
CEOs are either great leaders or great
managers
and from what I observe have observed
with Satya he is both
super Visionary really like
gets people excited really makes long
duration and correct calls
and also he is just a super effective
Hands-On executive and I assume manager
too
and I think that's pretty rare
I mean Microsoft I'm guessing like IBM
like a lot of companies have been at it
for a while
probably have like old school kind of
momentum
so you like inject AI into it it's very
tough or or anything even like open sort
the the culture of Open Source
um like how how hard is it to walk into
a room and be like the way we've been
doing things are totally wrong like I'm
sure there's a lot of firing involved or
a little like twisting of arms or
something so do you have to rule by fear
by love like what can you say to the
leadership aspect of this
I mean he's just like done an
unbelievable job but he is amazing at
being
like
clear and firm
and getting people to want to come along
but also
like compassionate and patient
with his people too
I'm getting a lot of love not fear I'm a
big Satya fan
that's so am I from a distance